oh your OBS crashed yeah I saw that but
it it'll
restart
[__] I heard that because I I heard a
little do you have a sound do you have
sound effects for oh I don't yeah yeah
when OBS crash yeah well you get like
this little popup error message that it
that it's like um connecting to the
internet it's kind of messed up that it
crashes yeah I don't know why it does
that but it works a lot better than it
used
to and at least it gives him a
little little popup thing yeah how is
this coaster
again no I I cannot find the CTR I can
just find a sit down
janola which actually looks kind of
terrible but that
on the side
node 142
ft okay I'm going to remove those
in-game paths as well I I'm I'm just
going to going to create a whole new
path
layout kind of need
that yeah it was kind of very crappy
make no sense q line was kind of
bad although the texture of the path
isn't too bad yeah but this path but it
was just like
yeah but it also doesn't have like the
two curves and three curves and all that
CH yeah and I kind of just want to use
the alpha p uh textures because you know
shadows and all
that mhm so delete all that [__]
actually I can turn
on Okay normal VI
again it should be working right now
yeah it
is mes it doesn't show viewers though
that's
weird yeah actually it used to have
exactly the same color scheme as my
let's
play invert that's a
coincidence like I did not even think of
that oh my God all these people are
going to be so [__] lost and they're
going to be annoying
[__]
ah oh
well oh okay oh my God I'm going to have
so much fun coming up with a
Japanese station using that set that
Ralphie made because I've never worked
with that set in my entire life before
also the support needs some fixing
the Hadrian that's that is kind of a bad
idea because then you lose all the
terror forming and I bet that's a pain
to redo that's a pain yeah because this
is a ter yeah although it it would kind
of be a good solution but then you would
have to do the supports again unless
you're going to yeah and the
terraforming and all that and I rather
just delete the pass it only takes like
minutes or so yeah
oh yeah that the support you remove
that's actually the one I found kind of
weird well I'm going to yeah we Infinity
we already found like oh yeah that one
need some fixing anyway like in that
time I was very much afraid of placing
supports and paths but now I realize
that you can just do
that yeah Infinity I'm pretty sure those
are chola
they look like the one I
found yeah this is now a janola inverts
just because it's cool and not mainam
and it's and it's no I wonder that if I
enter this and build it are the people
going to be like never seen a joola
before wow going to vote for this like
there there's only one in the world like
can invert and just just a handful of
sit Downs it's pretty do they even still
make
coaster I don't
know yeah I know you link to the three
seater but they look quite
similar oh I wonder why doesn't make
more coasters with B&M
track well
I think that's just kind of
something I like about intimate yeah the
fact that they could potentially do kind
of like yeah they could but like bnm
could also use the intimate tracks but
then the coasters would be or the the
cars and stuff would have to be yeah
okay but intim I'm pretty sure used the
TR before before B&M did
yeah but isn't it
that I
don't oh well I prefer the look of the
intimate tracks
though I like um PEX tracks they're
amazing especially the uh sea serpent
one yeah I also like like the Zer
tracks actually I kind of like I I I
really actually like the the new foma
tracks kind
of not I I've never been a big fan of
them I actually like them a lot for some
reason SCH looks pretty cool as well
yeah but that's like
really like the track
already already gives away that the the
the coaster isn't going to be really
Intense or anything it really looks like
it also doesn't look very smooth but
that's even worse with the arrow SL foma
old track
style
yeah holy [__] some of these supports
make no
sense I was a total idiot when it comes
to supporting it actually those Loop
supports are not that
bad
but actually I don't think I have a
better way of doing that not a much
better way
oh wait I
shouldn't SLC I don't know some people
really like
slc's I think I've done everything now
oh wait no forgot about some steel beams
fun fun fun fun looking forward to the
weekend oh wait no
[__] he aren't that rough Infinity like
the new the
new uh like inate Mega light cars seem
to be rough but like the hyper coasters
aren't that rough the
cars like that's the whole thing it
isn't the hyper coasters only have le
bars
so that just makes them not being
rough this is something that would make
sense adding these steel beam
tops no wait the normal ones over no no
wait the top ones wait
no no one over
there it's kind of like
that though I'll I'll have to add a
support in the side but
whatever
anyway I guess that
works oh you're talking about foma slc's
yeah they are
rough like the thing is
that they just
leave just the the space between my like
the two the two I don't even know like
between the the whole thing there's just
not enough space for your head to
not I don't know how to explain it but
it's just not
right basically flop
around black mama is not a Poma aslc
yeah like m is some of the some of the
greatest theming yeah black mama really
looks
amazing one combo where you at where you
at Happy Feet Wombo
Combo Fantasy
Island light what the valley that one
the CRA
isy [__] second two memories I was
totally reading fantasy I Fantasia land
I don't know why I did the same thing I
did the same thing I was completely why
I came up with black mama I I really
thought it was fasia land oh wow I'm
sorry you're probably like what the [__]
is he talking about like completely
showing him up mate R it the wrong way
wow covers on this stuff
stuff okay give me some where are the
Japanese path cover sets no no Japanese
path cover sets look at me making these
Kitty slides they're [__] two H high
or no two two tiles
High that's so so amazing path cover
yeah man Europa Park's pretty awesome
but it's not the best though it is
probably
probably the well I wouldn't say best
park in Europe I
mean alt Towers is up there and
fantas well Fantasia land I think I
think Ro Park's better than Fantasia
land probably better but I mean you also
have Port Aventura that's also a really
good Park holy [__] [__] it's not
removing the [__] path cover what
about the recre
from Tycoon one
hours that [__] was
dope did they have
it yeah they did it was out hati Park
and then Blackpool pleasure be holy [__]
I've got ter R coaster one I really
haven't played that game a
lot [__]
sake
my game Crash it won't remove the
[__] B cover what the [__] is
this dude it can remove all of oh there
we oh what theu Indiana
Indiana [__] up the entire [__]
coaster oh my [__] god finally gone
and what have I done in the meantime
[__] up the entire park holy [__]
[__] good uh kind ofs did I use over
here holy [__] I don't even
remember what what do these walls even
from uh they don't look like M's
walls but then what are oh wait that's
they're from ACA
NOS M steel
dick the best good
one yeah this [__] comes out of my
butthole when I scratch my ass yeah
exactly it's
like my
penis okay good this is a good set thank
you wait actually no that's not the the
right
color the right
places yeah oh yeah the Hadrian tried to
yeah he tried to correct his own BN M
but then then he already said Indiana
Jones intimate and then it looked like
you were correcting him as it being an
bnm but it's an
intimate okay so yeah it was kind of bad
timing need more I remove I don't think
I see anything which I thought I removed
so let's
[__]
continue [__] that [__] [__] okay I see
a footer that has a wrong col that make
no [__]
sense oh
nice oh my God I'm going to love messing
around with that Custom Scenery set
which I know nothing
of I might as well open it and see what
I can do with
that before I do anything
else so LP LP mid ping is it is it sweet
or salt popcorn because that's a big
difference and and did you make it
yourself because salt popcorn that's
actually from a from like jeries or I
don't know what that's called but like
like if if you make pop if you make
popcorn yourself salt is better but if
you get it in the cinema sweet is better
holy [__] I know right that's exactly
what it's like I
think almost everybody has that just
because like the site when you make it
yourself it's just
terrible
holy [__] this stuff is amazing this set
has got awesome sweet with extra sugar
oh that might actually be up this shit's
got ballast trades that go up holy
[__] [__] what support should I use
for a water slide this [__] is
awesome holy [__] [__] I should have
discovered this set so much earlier yeah
King the car's totally a
B&M it's not it's not yeah I know oh I
thought it was no I'm
kidding no we all know
Kanas we all know that K car is a px
coaster we all know it's um aood too all
coasters are pack coasters yeah it's a
wooden roller coaster come on guys yeah
it's a g
company no but like a wooden roller
coaster is not a company I think wooden
roller coaster is the best coaster
manufacturer in the
world yeah it
is it's really good it's got like loads
of um wooden roller coasters yeah
like oh cool I actually holy [__] why
did I even use the [__] bird house
set so much like I could have used
these I'm just going to use these in the
sides I think the bird house set goes
with this I'm just going to are you
[__] kidding me that then okay which
support should I use for for a water
slide because I have this water slide
support set but you cannot put the
supports underneath slides I don't know
this is
amazing I like these stone walls more
call them holy [__] these columns are
amazing dude oh yeah Kaka could actually
be aoma Boomerang though shit's got
dragons golden dragons holy
[__] this thing where it's at Japan you
ask which uh uh which set that is it's
Ral um I don't know Far East I
think uh it's it's more like Chinese but
Chinese and Japanese is pretty much the
same
so why as well
penis it's got stair
uh this not going to like can you build
Japanese shrines with this I don't think
you can but it's got some decent walls
but diagonals it's got diagonals that's
something worth mentioning you don't see
that every
day it's pretty
cool nice little
Windows wood paper wall things I'm
actually going to look which supports
pieces of prestige uses for his
slides Windows deep
what actually no I'm not going to use
those
wall to see if I can use these windows
over there holy [__] Japan intensifies
that works out he does it like that that
could actually wait what does pie of
prestige
do oh no I was looking at how he
supports his water slides but he
actually uses that sad but then just
makes them look
weird yeah he uses them in a pretty
really weird way you can yeah but if
you're not doing helixes you should just
use M steel jungle yeah but then it's
like and I think it's going to go
through the
slide yeah so no wait not if you use the
little um like one of the cups I
think oh wait I'm I'm going to use this
Mega coaster track connect that should
work well this is not even dude this is
not even my fancy yet my fancy is fancy
castles with fancy fancies and um fancy
everything so many details your eyes
will probably explode I I when I I just
can't stop building the right moment so
I I actually would like to keep my eyes
for a little longer just a little
longer long just just a
little add weird dragons no I should
not yeah Japan and China are the same
country don't worry
yeah so the Holocaust oh no it's like no
it's not it's not the same country but
you've got like the Chinese countries
like Japan is one of the Chinese
countries North Korea and South Korea
are also Chinese
countries Thailand kind no not really
Thailand is not really that Chinese it's
more like more like India in a way oh
yeah so wait so what you're saying is
let's play some James is Indian in a way
yeah makes a lot of sense yeah it does
make a lot of sense obviously now he's
blindian he's
blazian dude this this Asian gate is so
cool it's Swag in the maximum
swag 100,000 okayi you kind of have to
notice the sarcasm
though yeah well he did I think because
he left a smiley I don't [__] know uh
no he did not he did he said Japan what
the [__] Japan and China are really not
[__] one country left the smiley
yeah yeah North Korea and Finland are
separated that's actually really funny
but yeah they are obviously
Russia oh CCO I
joined yo G sup
dog he he just said no but it's actually
true so he's he's dumb l no he's just
saying we thought Europe up was a no
he's just dumb oh okay wait where's that
where's my [__] at where's that cool
[__] do I want these wooden
GS wow [__] is very light never
mind oh what does he moves in all the
right
places yeah we're going
Downes all the right faces oh god I've
listened to that song way too much
probably a very long time ago
though I'm silver red swear holy [__]
that did not work holy what okay okay
this guy just dude what it won't remove
the [__] object a a [__] no and now
was removing all this stuff stuff I
don't for [__] sake this is the this
is like the 50,000 time that this is
working with one of the objects that I'm
try to build [__]
sake now need [__]
Ste for [__]
sake [__] steak steak's awesome though
yo [__]
Ste nice
SN oh [__] [__] I just did it I didn't
mean to do it that was
random oh you support
or slides like that I really don't know
what to do I guess I'm just going to try
M Ste jungle and yeah but like then then
you can dude I need to make a water SL
support connector set yeah do it and
also with like flanges and stuff and
also with like toppers for like you've
got those glass slides you know with
like where the where the upper half is
made out of glass and stuff they've got
those Rings somebody also already made
those rings but only for one um only for
the raft slide and nobody uses that [__]
no nobody uses
that okay I know there's this sat who
covers
up the the little path thing but or the
the little I don't know what it's called
did you get that um ring set though I
don't think I
did unless you know what it's called no
I don't know
I have no [__] clue how to do this
[__] station so I'm [__] [__] at
that
point what did just
oh and I don't think the bird house set
works that great it's
like I don't
know it works in a way but then again
not that much I'm just going to try it
keep trying it works in a way but it
doesn't work though yeah I tried so hard
and got so
far it doesn't even
matter I have this I have this fence
slide
thingy we are very experienced at
singing and we all we always sing out of
syn and it's one of our
Specialties thank you for
noticing oh my God the the Bryan's wood
thingy works so [__] well with this
[__] Asian set and my dog is being
angry [__] abuse that [__]
[__] thanks dog thanks
dog I'm hungry now am I
hungry
H hi hungry my name is you really say
that way
often yeah wait too often you can't say
that too
often oh my God oh my God no oh God got
all
right tried so hard got so far in the
end doesn't even [__] matter oh D it
my
skin this coaster is just for fun this
is not a coaster for a contest
although
I you could
sub is
real you know I'll just give up [__] you
okay I don't think he is I just like
Lincoln par oh but in the end it doesn't
matter you could actually submit
this oh my God he like his own
jokes I oh
yeah don't know why it doesn't even
matter how there's
something hard you try
that that deep voice makes it so much
more
awesome wait
what oh my God that quiet voice was also
awesome you just heard him like like
slightly going
what
hey doesn't even matter how hard you
try it
does I actually don't like thinking Park
that much just wow okay just it's just
for the Montage
meme oh wait okay that
mes
evil hit
it so much work I actually no I'm not
going to do that never
mind wait I actually know something I
could do
okay in kyodo man with my man's SX
yeah CH Chong CH
Chong this is a Japanese coaster after
all so I kind of need to get into the
Japanese modood to B you guys in SK
other Jpop and baby metal all the
time well you can still play it because
I kind of like it yeah baby metal is
amazing
sugar yeah I've got 18 viewers only sh
Cann dude I've got 18 viewers that you
that you are in a Skype call doesn't
mean you can't play it because we have
to stream have to listen to it because
I'm using my headset
but like I wouldn't be able to listen to
you over that awesome awesome euphoric
baby metal going like yeah that's kind
of true probably and all that other
stuff oh they give me
chocolate I'm going to listen to it
now baby met that like I think like the
number one reason why all of these
shallow people only find gim me Chate is
because all of the other songs are like
weird
Japanese something that nobody can read
so yeah course people are only going to
fight give me
chocolate I'm listening to it
now yo probably probably people people
who who don't know the song
and people who don't know the song and
don't like metal are going to click away
in the first couple of seconds uh people
like metal dude the comment section is
so [__] up you've got all of these
people pretending to be metal heads like
going metal is dead and yeah Japan ruins
everything Japanese are idiots and and
and then they say they ruined metal like
how do makes no [__] sense at least
those people that something creative
those people like those those [__]
metal heads just need to stop being so
stop like getting their fingers up their
ass and just start accepting that people
want to do new stuff as well that people
actually come up with new ideas and not
do the same thing over and over again
mhm yeah this isn't a new coaster this
is actually
an abandoned project he's working on
yeah this thing is probably like two
years old actually that's not even a
joke thing is really [__]
old I remember when I was working on
this coaster back in uh in uh in uh
1939 the Germans were
invading
[__] but they couldn't stop me from
building this coaster yeah [__]
sake okay um L
okay well
okay okay now here the deal was a high
pitch voice help that was probably
toothpick oh he probably joined for a
second then where's the far was like
East Asia what's where's the where's the
japaneses
at oh my God building a coaster like
this is easy peasy
japanesey I get the joke
ring oh coaster Mike ask if if you can
do a POV and I'd actually like to see it
as well okay I'll do a I'll do a POV
your um um dragon fly but it's not going
that's not going to be the final name
obviously can you guys hear that yeah no
I can only hear your sexy voice I meant
the thunder in the
background hear anything so that's good
and up the lift here we go do we need uh
Rob LV sound effects or not oh the
stream is kind of behind though stream
is behind not in it yeah yeah in it yeah
I'm from Britain in it but okay need LV
sounds or not you're on it now we wait
no different camera position
twisty loop the loop twisty loop the
loop we this camera SE this camera is a
good camera Helix of death
wee Loop dloop my man my man boobs are
jiggling go 370 ft High into the vagina
cork screw although this coaster into
the
vagina we're going
keyholing Japanese coaster but it's
actually not a Togo we we're not on a
lock flum
y we are on a lock flum we are sorry
wait but the thing is if I'm going to do
sound effects just it isn't going to
match the stream because I'm watching
The Stream with commentating that isn't
gonna work yes it will
work just with a little delay little
little little
loopop little little
little Navy SE all all those all those
people just randomly in your in your
Park they're like on the [__] grass
like yeah don't they have
manners like you're not supposed to walk
on the grass oh wait never
mind oh my [__] God I forgot it's I I
was going to like keep the video on
paused mode but now all of the peeps are
pretty much walking toward the
exit
[__] oh my isn't that a good thing no
that's not good because I was going to
pause it redo the pathworks and then
play it again so it would actually work
now everything's [__] up thank you
guys but it's not a problem because I
still love you yes win hello I love you
winning who's that
that's too far
Patrick y SRE like Dro it
heart I'm going to be a dick to my
parents and I'm going to poke a hole in
every single coffee cup so like when
they take a sip it's just going to
squirt out
everywhere why why would you do
that
why I did it D was like what the
[__] and I'm like
um it's not
me I'm like I'm like um get a new cup
and what he did was he took another
cup and he put it over that cup so it
wasted a
cup what oh no a cup wasted that's
horrible was it a red Solo cup yes oh my
God you're so [__]
American I'm
kidding Americans only drink from Red
Solo Cup it said Netherlands sucks so I
poked a hole in it hey we don't
suck we eat you a that
sus
okay this milk's been open for some
reason like the there's no cap on this
milk and I'm still drinking it and God
knows how this caps on milk we have like
the it's a very complicated process you
have like the the paper [__] the [__]
kind of kind of [__] like there's a
cardboard and there's you need to like
do some origami [__] to open it wa wait
I actually got to look it up if there's
a tutorial on YouTube I open how to open
a Dutch milk thing no who open your milk
Buck do they do
they is a tutorial for it do they treat
milk like oh wait no that that's how
what do you mean like alcohol like is
alcohol is kind of hard to get open
because of all like the Cork and [__] so
it's like the way you guys are no we
don't have corks it's just it's just
it's just
alcohol it's just a [__] uh this is
just a guy who
makes ow tutorials on how to open yeah
that seems seems legit it reminds me of
those unboxing videos I hate those
things unboxing why is that [__] even
[__]
popular makes no [__]
sense and why do people even want if
they're reviewing it I understand but
it's unboxing de that looks pretty
decent but I would remove the horizontal
bars like right above the support or the
Footers I was trying to make a storm run
coaster that's kind of like top I got a
question for
it not you Jake um see how the the
sports go off to the left and then one
to the right yeah should I make them all
to the right or keep it like that well
it doesn't really matter that
much most of the time it the supports go
like uh
well into the turn but like if it goes
straight doesn't really
matter
the only thing I would say is um remove
those cross beams yeah that's what I
said have yeah horizontal beams yeah and
maybe you want to add some flanes these
are actually kind of 2006
supports that's when I stopped playing
well back that's when I used to I can't
blame you for it honestly no that's what
I'm used to doing cuz I used to do it
all the time a long time ago yeah yeah I
was maybe you want to you w to it took
me a while to get a bit a bit
wider it's actually easier as well if
you don't have to place cross beams it
save you it saves you a lot of time and
and it makes the support look more
realistic holy [__] this is the exact
set I'm looking for thank
you
oh thank you myself because I actually
found it so
yeah I'm so glad I'm me dud you're
even yeah
bro
yeah Tred so hard I got so that b boy in
there but in the end it doesn't even
[__]
matter hey sh stop spamming the [__]
rules you [__] idiot [__] m
nightbot
i I didn't know if if is like ignore
user is that just for everybody or just
for one person well at
least it doesn't really matter because
now I can't see nightbot anymore so yeah
that's
a it doesn't even
matter dude terraforming is [__] me
over holy [__] [__] dude what do you
think of like the [__] the
[__] okay there we go I think I
actually got [__] up your buildings
yeah there was like this small spot okay
there was a small spot where it wasn't
smooth it out okay so you could see like
um holy [__] [__] what's this even
supposed to be you could see the like
the
transition so the the I know what you
mean so like I I I use the smoothing
tool and Bam building is just [__] up
yeah but like if if you have the pool
selected like the the place pool
selected and you go like Fast buildings
it [__] up the building even if you
don't place it it's so messed up I think
Daddy
seven
ow oh well you can you can click on
nightbot name and then you can click
ignore user and then you won't see
anymore I just need to figure out from
which sets the from which set these
[__] brick walls came from I can't
tell
[__] H where where's this from I
don't even know you [__] recognizes
it probably
not oh 17 viewer hype we actually lost
some viewers so we're not going to
celebrate
that okay now which set could this be
from I have no [__] clue maybe it's
time to just find a different
set
uh make that 15
viewers
nice that's how we like
it but dude this make I don't know which
set this is from which guess I'm just
going to have to use different walls
like this this brick wall that I've used
over here you know what let's see does
that Ralphies the brick or the stone
walls well the stone the bom wall
one
um like those Stone ones are obviously
from old spices maybe the other ones are
from Old Spice as well might as well try
spice on my nut sack makes me
happy that's an awesome song you guys
should listen to
it I I I don't know it and I think
that's um that's good oh I'm going to
link it no you shouldn't I'll I'll just
link it in the in the chat probably
shouldn't supports
supports yeah my use those
support
roof okay we've got a bunch of different
walls over here so it's probably one of
those
things yeah it is one of these walls
time for a
celebration Good Times
on
celebration Good Times come
on you took a
holiday you have Jacob just one day out
of
life it would be it would
be and um hello Dr
crunch wait did I completely ignore
someone no holiday was here
before Dr crunch has been here for quite
some time yeah he just said German [__]
he said hello to me because I I I just
kind of
said
ah we're all living in
America America is
Wonder well Liv in America only country
done well this that son actually makes
fun at America and how like America
tries to dominate the world and yay it's
finally loading or actually done with
loading so that's
better cocacola
Wonder Hey don't do
that hey now that freaking floors are
all [__] up now I need to figure out
what the floors are from
hopefully they are from all spice set
otherwise I'm going to kill
myself that looks pretty decent although
the the the like the last turn to the
station is can't you like make that so
the S turn is not
needed but I got the breaking smooth
enough I like the the G screw gun I like
could also Bank the S turn but I like I
like the last part the best but you
might want to want to use some
horizontal bars on the supports from the
lift Hill but like a little you just
said don't do them so I took I only I
only meant the ones like oh uh just
above the
foods
in Ino but yeah that's the that's
basically the sentence that everyone
learns yeah I know I have learned that
in like my first lesson in German
ever and my dog is going crazy
again okay that's pretty
amazing that's amazing holy [__] that's
my that's my newest that's my new
status that's just the thing I'm going
to use when someone asks if I know if I
know
German holy [__] that's so
amazing we should thank him for that I
thank you Duna I thank you so much adato
Doo adato Mr Mr uh Dr
crunch Dr crunch that sounds like some
sort of American food like I don't know
cereal
kind of
actually it would so be an American
cereal yeah
actually extra extra crunchy extra
crunchy Frosted Flakes uh Dr crunch I it
makes a lot of sense I think I really
hope it's
already it already exists that would be
amazing it probably doesn't I don't I
hope it doesn't actually
up actually I make I should make these
the darker round you be stand a blur the
cool yeah right
uh that's uh very nice insult I always
like that to I always like to use that
one because uh schin H is way too
overrated and
overused that's kind of
true okay
this all talking Dutch now or German in
the chat now yeah yeah ah time BL cool
too too
much you guys know coaster Joe's uh B&M
connectors yeah I do there's no small
Helix like there's one but it's diagonal
and there's no regular one yeah it Le a
lot of pieces yeah but you can just like
try to find others that kind of fit they
don't have to fit
perfectly this is why I hated this game
cuz like whenever I made it it had to be
like exactly perfect yeah but that's
like then then you just want to use no
limits too yeah that's no wait that's
basically the community people going to
hate on you if if if it's not perfect
they're going to find one like you can
make an amazing coaster and they're
going to find one floating Bush and
they're going to be like ah floating
Bush not terrible [__]
off like I swear people are actually
like that
yeah I'm like that and speaking of
floating Bush they are the worst thing
I'm kind of like that but now like I
used well especially in No Limit but on
the other side of the spectrum you've
got the people always just say nice ride
and that's like yeah okay what what like
is my life better now since you've set
that
or that's kind of
useless so yeah um conclusion is uh RCT3
community of a bunch of [__] but it's
not close as bad as all the other gaming
communities actually a pretty nice
Community like
it and there aren't that many little
kids like there's actually bunch of
pretty old people in rcd community
yeah good thing I don't want to be in a
Minecraft Community like that like
Silver's almost an adult like so you're
so
old like so old I die
already that was a very nice thing to
say I know the [__] is with these
actually this this is kind of funny but
use different colors makes more sense
wait are these actually because that
would be kind of awesome and I would
love that make that going to make oh yes
they are thank this
set amazing set for having [__] in it I
I need
[__] still no um clo yeah oh clo up
here oh yeah clo up here does he star
Z
gu I love that song so much oh my God
that clo appear it's
amazing
gu I love it do we not speak English
anymore no we we speak
German how does this not I don't speak
German oh Herp Derp wow that was kind of
extremely
stupid such a
genius much well very Doge
X
um okay what was so funny about
that it's like you kind of joined in on
the
uh so that was nice
okay walkway frame what does that even
do I don't even
know it looks [__] useless so I'm not
going to use
it pump pipes okay that's way too
much needs more pon pon
pon okay what's
this I'm just going to use these H bars
you used for my for my
supports
nice
Horrors okay turn that turn that turn
that oh nice see
through an extended
supports
English can you please say the
word
I probably pronounced it that with a
terrible dude what the [__] dude just
he's just having a giggle you're having
a giggle
mate God damn it George Bush directed by
Michael B Oh that's oh you're
welcome I don't get it what I don't I
don't get it either I don't even know
what he
said now you he set directed by Michael
Bay was that like the waffle meme or
something I know there's like this video
on the internet where you see like a
waffle falling down and then as soon as
it hits the ground it explodes in a huge
explosion and then then it says directed
by Michael
Bay well Michael Bay jokes are always so
funny yeah they're very funny and
totally not overdone no no that's the
thing I like about them yeah
they're also not
predictable oh yeah that's that's
completely true there's so many
different variations those supports are
terrible holy [__] what are you talking
about my slide supports like there is
jungle but then it goes through the
slide make a connector and sketch up and
import it no I don't even have the the
sketch skills you need need although I
did make a complete station for No
Limits to which I'm pretty proud of dude
then you definitely do have the skills
but still I don't have the the the the
pre thingies the the [__] presets and
stuff and I have no clue how [__] God
I messed this up I I messed this
up still messed this up somehow it's
still bad at this game like oh my God
yeah I am bad at this game like I still
make this [__] thing like do the do
the weird weird
stuff do the weird stuff please building
please build thank you building for not
glitching on me you're
welcome thank you jcap mouse works
please have just yeah oh oh god of
course I'm actually going to try if that
kind of fits a slide but it goes through
as well that would actually looked quite
nice to be
honest okay now I [__] up wait could I
use
these no of course I could amazing need
to repair more [__] thank you Game for
being
amazing thank you community for not
having any slight
Connors my Tech Teacher comes from
Cameroon wow you're my German teacher
comes from England well that kind of
makes sense because you're in Germany my
German teacher comes from the
Netherlands
yeah oh and now that now there
[__] St with that HH please like what
was
why yeah but why would you just like
random letters it makes no sense those
those are the easy ones I I really need
to like practice that [__] again because
are you are you are you learning
Japanese I was a very long time ago and
then I was like oh wait RCT3 and then it
was no life rc3 and I was streaming for
27 oh well that's I still need to I need
I still need to learn Japanese I still
on my wish list I mean like three
languages isn't enough I also want to
kind of improve on my German but that's
not way like do I don't want to improve
my German at all no please no thank you
very much there's no way to really do
that like we go on vacation to Austria
three times a year like we've already
been to Austria more than 30 times but
still it's
me 30 times is Qui
sometimes
yeah like yeah like yeah like
whatever like oh my God like yeah
totally oops the intent I wonder what
the ratings on this [__] is like maybe
because it's a CTR the ratings are
[__] up but I don't yeah my excitement
my excitement is 20 dude my excitement's
over 20 my nausea is under four under
four I can basically
like make guests
pay2 to to get on this thing and they'll
they'll happily pay it isn't that
amazing the thing with these supports is
like from close it kind of goes through
a little but if you zoom out a little
bit it's like goes right through it [__]
are you using the Japanese keyboard
because if you are how [__] that that
[__] is way too [__]
complicated
so I guess on just I I E I would like to
learn Dutch and Japanese don't learn
Dutch it's going to kill you I promise
people say that Dutch is a is a hard
language to learn it's not if you
already know
English Dutch and English are very
similar many Dutch people say that Dutch
is a terrible language one of the
hardest languages um to learn it's
actually one of the easier languages to
learn because it's very similar to
English uh in in grammar and even in
many words and this m and the fact that
English is one of the it's the most
common language across the world makes
Dutch one of the easiest languages to
learn well if you if you know if you
know the Belgian language it's kind of
easy to
learn but Belgian people speak Dutch
what yeah that's
why thank
you I wish you were
gay no of course I don't I'm not going
to go that not going to do that
yet not
yet Dutch is too easy
yeah yeah nine well nine is not a Dutch
word but of course it is oh my God some
of that [__] German makes no
sense who blonds were driving to
Disneyland sign said Disneyland left
they started crying and went home can
you not
mate what that doesn't make a lot of
sense well like Disneyland left so they
were like a Disneyland left so then they
went home because Disneyland left so
there was no that's so funny yeah it's
probably American humor not funny yeah
CU it's a blonde joke cuz blondes are
stupid in
America oh aren't all the Americans
stupid that's kind of true oh wow I I
love how you said yeah because that's a
ridiculous stereotype that like the rest
of the world likes to use but every
country is full of stupid people yeah
especially
America that was not the message I was
trying to
convey
um there's only one country in the
entire world which which is actually
full of idiots and that's Belgium
obviously
yeah we have like this
NeverEnding make fun of each other war
with Belgium yeah it's pretty much the
same thing that America has with Canada
I'm pretty sure yeah kind of kind of
yeah
but Canada is actually a better country
than the United States yeah I agree with
that I agree on that no I don't even
know I don't think I know although think
I know about about those countries to
actually like theme park wise I I would
uh choose America though yeah no theme
park wise Switzerland is the best
country yeah and Ireland Ireland is
pretty dope and um Vatican City that
shit's got the best theme points yeah
and
Luxembourg yeah also pretty
cool lonstein is up
there Ria also has some amazing theme
parks
yeah
Alaska probably has some awesome ones as
well oh scrx drop is hard although
that's well Alaska America so Alaska is
United States
yeah it's [__]
huge I was actually waiting for someone
to say you know what else
well but that's too [__] immature and
you should not consider that
option well fact that that came up in
your mind is actually a bad thing didn't
it's really racist
though to on the clock
CL wow did you have to say that don't
make me don't
make don't make me change my Skype
profile picture again cuz of Tik Tok who
whoever said that no no no don't make me
do
it cuz who said Tik Tok yeah [__]
Ferrari oh hey America it's a white boy
over here saying [__] you should do
something about it I know right it's
so oh then again Obama said cancer and I
feel like everyone in the Netherlands
going to
be what the [__] you mean like the
crackhead guy or something but that's
like this this thing in Holland whereas
this is like they've got one heart like
basically to like pretty much everyone
actually thinks that um just saying the
word cancer is very bad it should only
be resorted to in the in the worst
possible scenario and even if you have
cancers the doctor cancer the doctors
are going to be like the doctors are
going to say like something um yeah um
we did you have you have it um we have
spotted it within your body yeah and
they'll just like and if you say the
wood cancer basically people are going
to kill you you know I'm not too much
against it but I wouldn't use it myself
no I won't use it but like some people
are
ridiculous both sides are ridiculous
like what's some people just just use it
like
247 yeah I I don't I don't care about it
but it makes seem very [__]
dumb
yeah
okay I love how Obama just went like
Isis is cancer that needs to be
destroyed yeah and then luckily in the
Netherlands you have quite some children
who are called
Isis Isis crisis really yeah yeah F
common
name okay I'm really liking my water
park so far wow you're so full of
yourself yeah I know thank you dude your
water park turned me
off okay
I bet that's a good
thing do G with this like next week Eola
is going to be
like the curs word to use yeah hopefully
not though it it turns out that the time
has come for everyone to make Ebola
jokes well that is as long as it's still
in Africa probably because as soon as it
hits the European continent people are
going to be like oh no [__] yeah but I
have never heard someone use it as a
curse word yet oh my
God I don't
know it's not going to become a curwood
because it's not
catchy I change my Skype profile
picture like that's the thing it's not
too it's not catchy
enough
there oh God when people use the wrong
there it's so annoying like 99% of the
time it's the it's the native speakers
doing it
yeah
like usually I I don't even care like
about a lot of stuff in my own language
but even in like a foreign Lang or in
this case English this just drives me
crazy it's so horrible but that's also
something else I always I don't know
you've got you've got the native
speakers especially on the internet they
just go LOL okay like like like like
whatever okay and then you've got the
non-native speakers who just try to
speak as formal as they can every every
single
situation like the people who are like
um excuse me for my English but I would
like to say that this and this and this
and this and this in the in the
situation and blah blah blah blah that's
pretty funny and then you've got and
then you'll get like an American going L
okay do you guys like my profile picture
let's check it out oh God Snorlax it's
Snorlax holy [__] it's that one YouTube
video where she's saying [__] I love
that
video funny while Snorlax
appeared there are actually Snorlax
party videos of that [__] it's really
funny
[__] silver reception picture look
guys it's it's an American making fun of
fat people ironic isn't
it I'm not like that I'm not like that
so I'm I maybe like maybe I a little
smaller than her
maybe maybe just a little just a little
smaller that's I I only drink Mountain
Dew twice a day and the last time h
Doritos was was about 5 minutes ago
so take that the last time I had a
Mountain Dew was maybe like about a year
ago and the last time I had Doritos was
probably like yesterday cuz I was hungry
last time I had was never I actually
really like
buritos they're
okay speaking of I need find some white
chocolate I I also never tast Mountain
do damn girl you'd be looking rough
that's what he
said what like it rough no no no no okay
look in the creators Lounge chat and I
posted that picture the Gazo picture
nice wait there's a chat going on is the
chat actually
active bit like I'm the one I'm the one
that starts it up again a little bit
who's on it why do you even have to make
a new account for the chat like yeah
it's why I'm not even going to bother
with that just because of that I'm yeah
I know right that's just an horrible
idea oh
God I like how like the non-native
English speakers are always like yeah
you Americans and English people who
don't learn any other language is stupid
but then again um as a non-native
speaker it's kind of learning English is
kind of easy because it's everywhere and
as an English speaker like what what
language should you speak because you
don't need
them kind of true
although then you would go for like
other world languages like Spain or or
Spanish no the thing is like in the US I
don't know why but isn't it like but all
those Mexican immigrants okay now we'll
teach Spanish at school like we'll adapt
to the [__] immigrants and we and
we're not going to let the immigrants
adapt to us I don't
know that seems like a very backward why
learn any language at all why not have
one worldly
language yeah uh English I suppose yeah
cuz it's most
spoken I actually like it the way it
is you like
what I like um up the butt
oh really so do
I high five so much in common no no no
no let's touch
tips why high five when you could just
you
know you know wink
wink not
Notch which set was it oh I think one
yeah good good good good good there's
some aluminum foil in my chocolate great
oh that's so tasty you're going to die
it was like wrapped in aluminum foil but
then it kind of melted and now it's kind
of Harden again and now the aluminum
aluminum foil kind of sticks to the
Illuminati yeah the Illuminati I was
just about to think and say
that fly press the
Border Master for for the New Order
don't mind that I'll protect Darth Vader
was the first black man to admit he was
the
father okay what are you doing Jay
there's popcorn between my
thots um it's it's teeth
um I'm giving you some feedback on
English I don't even
know which body part he means with teeth
I think though he could well made
something else like his toes
maybe or his titties I don't even
know his man titties no movies you
probably meant
tooth popcorn is
good but you don't you don't eat it
every day though you're not supposed to
well I'm not a not a huge fan of popcorn
I'm huge fan the popcorn Sten roll cuz
of Tycoon one um is the best thing in
the ever nah man yes don't dis well it
it has to be like like not not the plane
no not the plane one I mean like the
cassava one yeah that [__] is
dope sorry for that sorry for that like
pretending to yeah you better be sorry I
mean
now yeah is there any coww set with an S
Ben besides uh the atth one um um um
I've got an idea ditch that at set
because it's absolutely terrible and I'm
not using it I'm using
um it's called I don't know it's French
or something oh yeah that that's a good
set I think that oh do have I don't
think that has uh yeah I know that's why
I asked cuz I couldn't find one yeah I
don't think oh but that's the best set
out there so maybe you just to try to
not add a
catwalk I that's the only solution to
that
I'll just add the spiral staircase at
the end of
the
yeah oh that s is is really annoying to
work it's like record a [__] all the
stupid French
names that's one reason why people don't
like French people they they like their
own language to they don't learn any
other languages and when they make us
some scenery sets even make the sets in
their own language like could you not
guy inspector
man oh no don't walk over the water
please that's against the
rules is it still holy [__] [__] I'm
not even going to read that like all
those words look look at what Dr crunch
just posted yeah but he's just like
aiming to
yeah no he left my Park my beautiful
beautiful water park dude dude no
teachers are gay don't say that you
don't say that teachers
suck wait you actually learn to speak
Latin that's actually really cool we
only translate it oh my name is Lara
well then that's really simple in Latin
so wait your name is
Lara that's ni is it a girl oh my God is
it there are no girls in the internet
this
no this is against the rules I think I'm
I'm going to have to ban you now yeah we
should this is not good uh makes me
think of Lara
cross that's F it's weird cuz the she
looks like lcraft no one likes her
actually all the nerds do yeah well no
one likes the nerd so it makes sense oh
wow no ban her no oh God n no now we do
now we do want on pictures though yeah
that's true dude post the rules post the
rules post the rules look
look [__] rules you cunch there 30
there are girl the internet yeah 31 tits
sword you get the [__]
out oh
God wait what happened to your stream oh
it just kind
of dude I am 14 how is that an exception
when you're 14
yeah that is I can still get them I've
got I've got plenty of child porn in my
PC it's not a
problem I don't have
enough I don't have any cuz that's
weird you have the Omega one or the
Omega I thanks for telling the NSA is
probably listening and like going oh he
has t one on his PC exterminate him fly
some American helicopters to Holland in
the name of freedom and liberty and
let's let's take him no well that's not
my
problem I still need to delete that file
but I don't know I want to save it
somewhere but I just can't do that dude
I should just save it on like I don't
know
um the the network like our family
networking thing the network the network
you know the V Network v Network what V
Network oh you can also say the network
what no but like if you say the it's
like it's cooler what yeah no it's
not yeah it
is screw the parking Spectre no he's
awesome just leave him he can walk over
water you know how awesome that is can
he actually walk over water he was sent
by God you know I have those those those
little things on the water and in order
for the peeps to go sit in
they have to walk over the water wow
that is amazing dude I'm going to try
that as well and just [__] make a
video of it and release it as the great
wonderful Ultra delicious
um Jesus guy Jesus the park inspector I
mean Park inspector
Jesus and then just um kind of make a
video of him cloning bread or something
as well I don't even know what is a
ruffle copter you know what you don't
know what a ruffle copter
that's like very dude that's a very old
school internet thing you've got like
you know rfle right like rolling on the
floor like like this um a c i art where
you like make a a helicopter using
[__] characters and then animate it
it's pretty fun and then and then then
the rule copter goes SW SW SW SW
SW
interesting you definitely need to look
that up that's a good piece of Internet
culture from the from the
from the from the good old times it's
great I love it I used to love was
like 10 I don't know the rle copter is
an internet phenomen of the flashlight
new
GS the term is a selling from r l
rolling on the floor laughing and Ang
hat
helicopter drop it hard four Builders
and roller coaster roller the roller
coaster is also amazing shut the [__] up
truck that [__] is so
ging
oh
hi reckle holy [__] reel kind of joined
the party very late yeah REO why you do
this REO why you do this why you do this
why you do
this inspector will you do this
yes oop oh that was an uh interesting
addition to the
conversation yeah
exactly
what the [__] you sa me a little [__] I
have you know
I I've been involved in numerous in
al-Qaeda I've been over 300 confirm
kills I'm training gorilla Warfare I'm a
top of sniper entire you with Armed
Forces you're nothing to me but another
Target it sounds like something murf
would say how 20 viewers dude
dude what that's that's totally
something M would say dude I need to
edit that [__] you nothing to me but
just another dude I need to edit that
let go what the [__] did you just say
about me you little [__] I'll have you
know I I made uh numerous amazing
tropical B&M and I graduated and and
I've been sent by God to make
them oh do it I'm actually I'll do it
I'm going to do it I've actually made a
a roller coaster version of that copy
past somewhere but I lost it it's
somewhere on my computer but I can't
find it
anymore but I really need to find that I
did the entire copy pasta so that was
really funny
anyway I need to add some
stuff how the [__] did he do that oh who
it seems
like what um people can walk through the
rocks and walk directly out of the pool
nice is game so there's a secret passage
through the Rocks which is secret
passage oh very interesting I no much
secret very
Illuminati Illuminati passage to the
Pope's residence oh well nobody will see
that
probably drop
it I I I really need to use bricks the
old
bricks
REO I do want you to be aware that LP
mid pudding is a girl
so yeah what why did you say that I
don't know that makes no [__] sense
you're being a sexist
yeah well ain't that
sexy
go go
this parking can I inform you that we
are all just [__] nerds sitting
behind a computer and the the the Mortal
body that we possess doesn't really
matter at this point because we are now
in a digital world at least I don't have
classes [__] I do [__]
you I know you I do but I wear
contacts dude I I wasn't that that was
that was Croco you can blame Croco from
for being a sexist [__]
yo I don't even care all I care
about3 can you look at that picture um
makes me want to kill myself this
picture I need a good thing I
think which picture time to do some
[__] oh thank you thank you so much
holy [__] the the last one oh the one
with the supports I can't get one that
fits it well you don't need a support
there I mean that turn is supported well
enough I think I I am a girl and you are
a monkey sitting on there still should
be like a that fits it on the keyboard
I'm not sure I understand yeah that's
pretty weird have you tried turning
these supports if that makes any
difference oh yeah I just figured out
you can turn them in changes them five
minutes
ago would h
H this sucks might use these
wooden well there should be one that
fits it considering you did found one
for the other half of the turn you used
the double past T that is
unacceptable
sorry um pieces of prestige one set that
to me and I wanted to get
revenge I'll Retreat okay I'm going to
go downstairs so I'll talk to you
tomorrow I guess okay bye byebye
everybody wait that ended the call oh
damn it someone
please I don't even
know I'm just going to I might call
again if they don't might always do
that I might as well play
uh Jpop but I don't know if that's a
good thing to
do no okay they're not going to do it
never
mind oh that didn't that worked out why
is this C called no scope 3 makes no
sense anyway my Skype doesn't work
anyway
so oh wait or does it oh it does
work
wow there's a guy named silver rat yeah
that's I'll be
me yo Dev oh wait I thought
that oh never mind I wonder why why Reco
not in it oh well
whatever
for some reason my uh twitch chat is
failing to
load that sucks mine is
working like no just just mine yours is
working
fine yeah you did get a a screen of my
Skype name my my Skype name is
amazing yeah that
happened flash failed what what the [__]
to be fair my real s name is just
silverette and it's not not a secret or
anything and Dr crunch what are you on
about
like what why do you name record but I
didn't got the call okay that's weird
because
you're in this in this chat
thingy H you didn't even say anything
about how I pronounced your name name
that means um you must think it's good
though I'll keep calling you Reco in
that
case oh my God twitch St I'll add you to
the call if you want it to you wanted to
I don't even care this is the no scope
call and I own this
call um where wait
um
Google but that didn't work
out beautiful absolutely beautiful love
it oh my watch the video why do I need
okay I'll check it out to see what it is
but oh that's I've already seen it it's
amazing especially that entrance thing
and the color scheme is gorgeous I never
expected blue and yellow to work that
well but I guess the shades are really
nice H that's really
weird oh wait that's probably uh who's
calling right now because I think it
depends on who's the host like the host
I don't
know need to have them like as contacts
H
strange hey guys who's hosting this I
started the
call like I I called everybody else like
exping that they yeah wanted to join the
call but it didn't work yes I'm in the
call holy [__] it
worked congr Lions
nice
oh
nice okay so it worked after
all
yeah yeah
mate yeah mate wait actually I shouldn't
use the same fences all over the place
that gets boring as heck remove this am
I now famous on
Twitch yes you are very
famous right now there are 17 people
listening so eight 18 18 just legal so
um very
nice 18 viewers
hype
yeah no actually no there's no
hype no h no
no just see do
hype but s did you finish the the layout
for no scope
Tre
nope but I did check it and it kind of
worked pretty well but some parts still
need fixing but thing is I'm not going
to uh finish it on a stream because that
was too much lag to synchronize it
perfectly yeah yeah that was
unfortunate I'm just going to use these
Asian columns as fense columns oh wait
that
doesn't
[__]
uh
uh wait now it
works
huh okay I can see see why okay screw
this this thing has a random size
placement that makes no no
sense like you know how foliage has like
this random size thingy yeah well this
same thing makes no sense
wow why do you want to have that on the
post really well I I kind of wanted to
get
posts yeah why do you
even add a different height thing
because I want to add a railing on top
of this thing yeah but why do you add
that as a creator of the set I mean not
that
you I don't know my idea I
guess I'm just going to mess around with
the ropes first then I don't know maybe
I can use ropes and of
this it
works
only problem being that I'll have to
post the the [__] post manually that
really
sucks I hate do that lazy no it's just
no
it's lazy
like don't like it when I need to do
that the oh high can join the call H
that's strange let's see what if if I
can
well
H it's it's not even he's not even in
here the
oh at
him but I am not really the uh host of
this call
so
NE
like this
is every time this happens it reminds me
of the first stream I ever did since I
did that announcement the nightmares but
so far it's it's always been good good
good oh by the way this is
why okay if you look in the Skype chat
that's what I that's what I put as a
command you just got to type in murf
you make that a command where you're in
mod yeah no for
night okay okay I'll make I'll make that
command
what yeah
it's come on go to night spots I need no
wait that's not enough well actually it
does work I I'll edit it I mean
just it needs more um I will run over
you then
keep you're just a bump in the road then
I I I I'll edit it to make it more
perfect okay it'll be a collaboration uh
thingy silverette I mean whoa whoa whoa
whoa it goes
all I'll make a I don't
know now rically he spelled most things
he said right that's the that's the
funny thing ironically how's that ironic
I don't know cuz in a flame War like
that people just tend to just flat out
just flame not really care for their
spelling
okay there is no need for snipers
because snipers is overrated command
name
murf command response he's GNA find our
streams like what the [__] yeah I
will okay so this needs to be you are
just
a bump in the road yeah that's what I
put run
over keep on
going there's no stopping a
dream MH mhm I was sent by God God needs
to have a capital letter you wow did you
not learn the Christian ways I thought
you were
American I'm the king of icbe
because no
one maybe you don't need to make that
too long else you will annoy yourself
later you guys just take this game too
serious
um no
wait
and and then it needs to end with
um immature sentence goes here oh yeah
oh my God I almost forgot about
that add
command I didn't even lose viewers
that's nice no it needs to be with a
capital letter so like oh wait actually
that doesn't matter I think
doesn't why is it not working pretty
sure I added
it there is murf over there
murf what's this
everyone should be able to use
it
what I made um a panda coaster command
what it's not working oh did somebody
mutes um let's let's try other command
actually
what well this this is obviously not
working why is it not
working
this makes no sense can you add commands
mid
stream yeah you can you should be able
to do that like okay let me let me try
another command okay uh it has been
updated but that's probably not going to
work uh what else is a terrible command
um oh these ones are amazing the year
one needs to stay obviously oh [__]
these are all too good to
remove let's see dedit where
wellan n espan thing is not great let's
try a different command
Okay
um what's a word that many posts start
with hello hello
yeah well hello couldn't work but yes
okay yes I'm just going to use a command
for
yes yes and then it will say yes yes yes
girl I to
pay M doesn't
work that's that that's the question
yeah yeah that
one it doesn't want to work on murf
maybe it can't be because of the squares
because it works on Navy
SEAL
yeah H I'm just going to create the
command again like maybe it's because of
the like if I update it maybe it works I
don't
know I don't know let's see does it work
now
Earth yeah that yes it
worked not
that I got to see this
any
yes yes here for
Wow needs more plugs I have a panda
coaster Comm
in dude that's a great idea like
whenever he enters we just need to spam
that is the talent
G wait you hate me why do you hate me
what what did I do wrong what
what okay doesn't work suck
okay yeah okay okay right now it's three
night commands
um let's see you know what these things
look ugly AF just going to try something
else in the diagonals just going to try
to some half
diagonals this looks like
[__]
right okay okay for the pan coaster
thing says this stream gives me some
serious cancer with the
UR that's not enough probably pente coas
has more things than that I know that
that's a good idea but that's a good
idea pentas command is a good idea okay
uh what else can we remove while giraffe
honestly is outdated so Pender coasters
but giraff Panda actually Panda will rff
oh wait I put need to start with what's
this because that's what he always
says what's this um
feminism
Anarchy racist
racism [__]
Jews
um uh thoughtful
discussions
yeah for some reason a murf command does
not want um doesn't work for me either
there no I'm I'm trying to test it
out M works for
me why does everyone hate nightbot
nightbot is awesome night spot is
awesome
Panda oh he it filtered [__]
no but still like why why why do you
hate me what did I do wrong I didn't do
anything wrong did
I how do I get 22 viewers for this [__]
anyway uh I need more where's P I need
to edit that because I don't want I
don't want little Aster in in my
command always use the AZ defense so no
I'm just going to do something else then
I don't want to use the a defense either
that's okay
uh hello there my name is nightbot I'm
rcg [__] what's something else that
pente coasters always talks
about glorious well he actually doesn't
talk about politics that's Chris oh
green
text this will do I
guess oh my God have you having a giggle
mate I'm sorry
o you [__] white me I sucking n you
okay Panda
what but um mute night what does that
work ban night
Bots these B&M connectors are so trash
nights
LOL
so you happy now like
it I
not need more ropes I really need to do
some serious [__]
again some of these plugs I hate doing
fences and stuff especially when it
takes a long
time I don't know why I always love
doing defenses yeah if you're using like
easy sets and stuff but this is one of
those set we have to place ropes and
then little poles and then little wood
[__] and other things and it takes ages
and you barely see anything of
it I'm having the worst time with these
B&M connectors oh yeah that's that's
terrible
yeah they look right but it's just
getting them right is always such a
hassle yeah like with a steep slope to
Flat without going like to Gentle steep
is just steep to Flat that long one you
can't get one that fits it perfectly
there's always this tiny little Gap and
it bothers me so much yeah for some
reason
this murf command is not working it's it
should yeah but that's because I banned
night
bots on my on my stream like I'm typing
in M it's like no doing
anything did they come out with an
inverted B&M connectors yet no he's yeah
he's working on it but he's been working
on it for well over
year yeah it's not going to come out is
it God damn it wait there's a grass
texture this makes no sense let me try
that maybe that that's handy
somehow wow dude I might actually use
that that's really nice going to try
using that honestly like is using the
grass yeah is that a good idea to use
that but probably too much work yeah but
it would look pretty good I
reckon yeah yeah I'm just going to try
it but you need to place every single to
to look good to look good that's the
problem yeah well I'm just going to try
it either way and I also feel like
changing up those little things in the
middle but I can always try that later
on first I'm just going to see what I
can do with those
off oh
no best from Kill a
kill yeah mate you can't just disagree
with that no
no
no no no no no no no no no no
no no then no I staying clean
oh oh no no no I at the burrito now now
now now I I I fart
[__] had I had Catherine
as
what what Catherine nothing no I'm not
going well she she'll take offense so
I'm not going to do it no no no I no it
says hey there has grabs the iron grabs
the iron 5T slm pole oh
[__] oh it's
oh it worked wait wait all these work
but why doesn't [__] murf work murf
works oh wait on yours yeah that's
because saying that's because of the
records the green text records it it
doesn't work with that so you have to
REM you have to remove the little
brackets in um immature sentence goes
here [__] all right so I'm to do
parenthesis I
guess oh I was I was getting scared I'm
like no I can't do
murf no D dude no that's
nasty yeah there we go got
it what the [__] did you say to me you
little [__] I'll have you know I'll
have you know God gave me the talents to
make roller coasters you are an SE to me
I will run you over like a bump in the
road I've been creating numerous
coasters before you even born I'm the
king of RCT3 you're my [__] there's no
stopping a dream I've always create a
maze you take this game too seriously I
forgot that I forgot that iot that I
always create sceny Tycoon immature
sentence
go I need to add that as well what is my
first page MF there we go that's the new
Navy SEAL
command
I feel so bad we also need to create
like an antim
murf I don't know someone who just goes
like oh this is terrible there's not
enough ground Shrubbery the supports
suck the layout is unrealistic you need
to use B&M connectors and then somebody
else could use murf and go no shut up
[__]
I'll do
it
it's yeah I got four
commands um I'm going two more for the
alpha grass path cover
thing wait I need to look what it looks
like with that see what it looks like
without that that's actually uh slightly
better
he it won't let me remove that
good and I don't even need to install
any new textures for this that's
cool is that a brown Trevy silver
yeah I know I still need to [__] work
on that I was kidding oh my
God fence
taken
fence a fence
taken what would it look like actually
that doesn't look that bad like just
some lighter
grass way if you
will like
it
okay
then um maybe the
flowers it's more lively now you know
it's not pled anymore with that c yeah
it's amazing I love it new
religion
religion need more oh wait
phone just kind of her
dered I need to load the stream
again
people
silverettes oh that's a bomber no yes go
back to the stream that grass cover I
know right it's very
sexy what's all this
about Max is actually streaming as well
wow no Dy Max why you do this why you do
this also um my beautiful face love
it giggle
there oh wow I I really need to smooth
this
out how could anything be this UNS
smooth holy
[__] oh well do that later
on those grass textures though well
it very long time to do
though just just make like a 5x5 and
save it and then just copy it everywhere
but does it still terraform if I do that
it might I'm just going to try
it it wouldn't hurt to try yeah make a
4x4 though um only problem is overlap uh
if they overlap you're going to have
weird Alpha textures and I don't want
that so have to be really
careful
Ross
cross I'm going now downstairs okay this
doesn't work out okay boy yeah then I'll
stay at this height so
yeah sucks something as structure
doesn't
work I do that with support Killers yeah
I know it's it's it's I I feel like it's
the only way to make support killing
actually something that I could do
otherwise I I just can't stand
it you have like a thousand different
saves
yeah I think like the the upper one is
the support
killer I'm almost done my supports hpe
it the [__] up I forgot how long this
takes especially with
my like how I want
them oh supporting always takes a long
time especially with that B&M connector
set
uhhuh I hate
it yeah but it looks great that's the
one number one reason why some people
just refused to use it but I I figure
that my coaster looking great in the end
is something more important than my
laziness to not use a very not user
friendly
set yeah I remember when I used to use
uh
the what is it hold
on holy [__] there's so much nice spot
spam what time is it it's time for clock
I don't
know I'm in the same time zone as you
are
so maybe Seal's gone
Oh Oh I thought it was I thought you I
thought you plac it with murf I did yes
I would never replace an NC with
murf
certainly though that [__] still really
flocks the spam so I
might ban nightbot again if this keeps
up I'm strugging with my final Comm
in holy [__] this grass why don't more
people do this the only thing that I
miss is like little grass like actual
grass like this is still just a texture
like like what I like is actual grass
like little grass
thingies sadly there's no released out
of that only some betas but never
actually
released apparently the lag monsters too
but I wouldn't care I would just do them
in the end and then when the grass is
done do the
filming hey come on no don't do
that nightbot is on as always hey oh my
God I just deleted a
support great is nightbot a person no
it's like it's it's this bot and it's
supposed to help you moderate the chat
so you can give it commands and make it
add spam filters to it but I've disabled
all of the spam filters and added
commands that are basically
[__] so instead of actually like
deleting Stam spam it's kind of like
more like spam
monster a
s oh my God this grass is
amazing
wow love it very No Limits e but not
that no
limit
My milkshake brings all the boys to the
yarn and they're like it's better than
yours damn right it's better than yours
damn right I can teach
you my Pokemon brings all the Nerds to
the yard and they're like you want to
trade cards damn right I want to trade
cards I will trade you my
Charizard this is an
America they don't want me they can't
have me so I just danc the
macarina CU a Tycoon 3 and okay hey
Macar Jake you hear that Thunder
bud you scared of
it what remembered to throw up every
time I
thundered that doesn't make any
sense if I was you I would
safe nice gross everywhere gross gross
gross gross everywhere
grass here grass there Grass Grass Sil
yeah what holy [__] saving you're right
so much spam holy [__] such spam holy
sugar holy
wow
sugy
very gr
texture looks awesome look